we begin in israel where at least five
people have been killed in a gun attack
local media is reporting that a single
gunman opened fire in several areas of
bene barack which is the city near the
city of tel aviv the national ambulance
service says the attacker has been
fatally shot it's the latest in a series
of attacks in the past week
well let's get more from our
correspondent harry fawcett who's live
in west jerusalem harry what more are
you hearing
well initially the reports were that
this attacker was on a motorcycle and it
was some sort of a drive-by shooting in
separate locations inside bernie barak
which is uh an ultra-orthodox sort of
city or neighborhood of tel aviv a very
densely populated
part of the country
there has been disturbing video that has
emerged since which shows the gunman
walking having already it seems shot two
people who are seen prone behind him and
then firing again
there is a
someone on an electric bike who zooms
past and just escapes narrowly uh from
being shot himself and then the gunman
is seen to confront a car at very close
quarters demanding the driver stop
before apparently shooting him dead as
well so now we have confirmation that
five people have been killed one
seriously wounded has apparently
succumbed to their injuries and as you
say this is the third large-scale such
attack uh in a week
one in besheva in the south on tuesday
where the attacker used his car to ram a
cyclist and then stabbed three other
people before being shot
then two gunmen in hadera in northern
israel on sunday night opening fire near
a bus stop killing two young israeli
security forces members
before again being confronted and shot
by police and now this as well so this
is a major security situation for the
government to get hold of it is reported
to be the bloodiest weak inside israel
in terms of attacks on israelis since
2006.
and has there been any reaction yet from
israeli authorities or palestinian
groups
uh yes there has been well at least uh
there's been a convening of a major
security meeting by the israeli prime
minister naftali bennett that is due to
got underway just as we were coming to
where among those around the table at
that meeting will be the defense
minister the head of the shin bet
internal security service the head of
the police the head of the army uh and
so they are taking this extremely
seriously uh in terms of other reaction
uh well there are two levels i suppose
in terms of street reaction we're seeing
uh reports of people gathered in bernie
iraq at the scene
chanting death to arabs a huge amount of
anger calls for revenge
near janine in the occupied west bank
where
we understand the attacker the suspected
attacker comes from he's reported don't
have confirmation of this to have been
working illegally at a construction site
in bernie barak his name uh dia hamashi
uh said to be 26 years old and reported
to have been arrested in the past and
imprisoned in the past for some months
uh on security grounds uh by
the israeli military um so there are
people there that have been gathering
and uh chanting in support of his
actions and again there has been support
for his actions coming from both hamas
and palestinian islamic jihad hamas
saying that the attack shows the unity
of the palestinian people palestinian
islamic jihad saying it's a harbinger of
our people's operations to go deep
inside what they call the zionist entity
otherwise known as israel so
this has already been lauded by but not
yet claimed in terms of responsibility
by two of the major armed fighting
factions inside gaza
harry fossett they're bringing us the
latest on that shooting in israel thank
you
[Music]